ああああ
ああ
バーなんですかね
サーフィン部そうやし僕は音楽とかアート
とか
ソース20代前半で言うとなんかそういう
あの
なんかワクワク者に楽しかったりすること
を
に触れている時間を大切にしたというか
なんかそっちを優先したんですよ別の僕家
が裕福なわけじゃないからお金にいねえ
余裕があってじゃなくて他に逆にまあ
どっち買ったら貧困というかお金持ちだね
お金ない環境に育ったので
いろいろお金の問題があったんですけど
なんかそれを無視して
片親でて母親がいねえシングルマザーだっ
たりして色々家の問題あったのに俺は何か
20代前半それを
知らないふりをして
春の自分がやりたいこと
貫いたっていうかそっちに行ったみたいな
自分の練習
生きていく
自分の園生活とか自分ですね最低限仕事を
色々な日や木雪労働者みたいなこととか
なんか
人材派遣で工場行ったりとかはしたりだけ
してたけど必要以上に働かなかったという
かそうサラリーマンにもなりたくなかった
し
もっとその自分がやりたいとか見た行こう
か興味を持った
surf art music みたいな
ところに
行きたい時に行ける
時間を max 暮らし方とか生き方を
選んで
就職とかもしなかったし
それはそうそれさっき言ったよう余裕が
あったがそうできたわけじゃなくてそう
いう式を櫨木切ってない
つやんなきゃいけないことを自分に迫っ
自分が置かれているその経済的な
向き合わなきゃいけないその課題とかお風
応援の方とかっ
それをやったせいで30ダックス
bookoff 暮らし苦労したんです
けど
まあでも20代などその
勢いがある時にやっぱ
お金とかに取らずにとらわれずに
自分がやりたいことをやりきったというか
いろんな人に会っていろんな場所に行って
そう
なんか
30代後でこういろいろ公開模試ね今も
後悔ないことはないけど
なんかまあそういう
公開もあるしそれをやるべきことをやら
なかったせいでいろんな後から宿題が倍に
なって返ってきたりで30代過ぎて大変
だったけど
30代2が35歳以降ぐらいかな
今も大変なんですけどう
普通の人って言ったらあれ世の中の大半の
人たちがあ
あの
当たり前に就職して当たり前に時間を取ら
れてねそれはお金のためにあったりとで
将来の安定の為だったりとかそのたびに
眠いの就職するね
なんか僕はそうじゃなかったよな
そこに捕らわれたくなかったと言うがが
強いというか
遊び人なのか海楽主義者なのか海楽主義者
と言われたこともあるな
そう
でもそうなのかもしれないです
ソースまあ家庭幼少期の家庭環境がそう
バイソン
裕福じゃないなっつーかな乳児的じゃ
なかったから
まあ
家庭グライムスはし学校とかもそうやし
振っ加工
順風満帆じゃなかったぶーその
世界に対して社会に対して学校に対して
家庭環境に対してあの
不満もあったしこうなって欲しいんだ欲求
があったのでまあそれを変えたい気持ちも
あって
もあったしその現実感に件逃げ違ったのは
両方やったと思うそれが
なんか自分の行動に脳は聞きさ基礎という
かソ行動のなんか
他の人と違う動きをした
理由というか要因の一つやったと思う
暖家のにできなかったんでしょうねきっと
ね
そう簡単やなことなのに誰でもできるのに
結局人間自分も含めてその弱い
っていえばいいしいわー
弱い人はあのなかなかそれができないん
でしょうねで強制スイッチが例えば分かり
やすくいうと離婚行ったりとかね
そう taboo
なんかやらなんかこう
外部の
外的要因がないと
動けないんじゃないですかね僕も含め意志
の弱い人
そう
まぁ僕の場合そういうことがあったんで
まあ
あとはまあ
金銭的なでプレッシャーって課題とか妄想
だし
なんかやっぱりこ問題が
大きい
それ目つぶってられる間ぐらいのレベルの
問題だったら結局目つぶって逃げていたら
いいんだけど僕の場合はに目つぶって逃げ
られるぐらいいろんな問題があったから
強制的に立ち文化ざるを得ないというか
そうそれがねあの
体調とかにも
肉体的なその
影響も出てきたりねなが胃腸炎になったり
とかパニック障害みたいになったりとか
結構そういうのもあったから
そう
なんか病院には朴正意志が強いのかじゃ
ないで行きたくなくて
病院に行くほどの重症じゃなかったからが
良かったけど勝手にのっ
やっぱでもそれは無心体的な影響とねっ
なんかこういう問題が出てきたりとかまぁ
社会的ななんかそういう問題が出てきたり
とか
どうかそういうのがあったからやっぱ
動かざるを得なかったんですよね
そう
僕ば多分20代普通にチャット何か仕事と
かしてたらそんなことにならなかったと
思うんですけどね
そう金銭的なことも含めて自分がやりたい
ことじゃなくちゃんと
経済的なまずはベースを整えることが大事
奴って俺が20大学卒業してちゃんと働き
出してたら
多分
こういうことに30代することになってい
ない
けどますができなかったが20代のツケが
回ってい
それが
まあ結構こんな感じですねこわーと
サーフィンだ音楽が伝統文化の藍染らー
お遍路ガス地方で故郷アドや言ってるけど
なんかそれは中に社会というくん
せめてものアレなんかも自分の人生を肯定
してもらうために何かやってたみたいやっ
てきたみたいなところもあるかも
自分が自分の人生を肯定するためにもそう
だし周りにを認めて欲しいみたいな
でまぁ者か世の中自分の自信の問題も含め
てだけど
社会全体とか自分の周りを見渡したときに
見える問題
名的に見えてくる問題をに対して正
それじゃあどうにかそれに対して何か
アクションしてちょっとでも改善できる
よく自分がそこに対し少しでも貢献でき
たら
世の中にも見ても認めてもらえるんじゃ
ないかなみたい
結構世の中に認めてもらいたい欲みたいな
すごい強いの本